welcome to their famous Friday I believe
that whatever your goal is whatever
obstacles in front of you it's already
been solved by somebody else and the
fastest way for you to get to where you
need to be is to model success of people
who've already been there and apply it
to your business so today's lesson is
from George Lucas founder of Lucasfilm
and it's believe in yourself who fit for
this channel right so George Lucas was a
director and he had had some success
with his first movie that was American
Graffiti and he wanted to create a new
one called Star Wars and he had it
produced with Fox Pictures and he did
something different he did something
that nobody else did at that time they
wanted to pay him half a million dollars
to create Star Wars and he said you know
what I'll take a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars I'll take a three
hundred fifty thousand dollar pay cut if
you give me two things one the rights to
do any sequels I own it and two the
merchandising and this is a time when
merchandising didn't really exist for
movies there weren't you know plates and
cereal boxes and action figures for
movies that didn't exist and there
weren't a lot of movies that went to do
the sequels that had series so Fox
thought this George Lucas guy he's an
idiot he wants these two things that
nobody cares about and he's willing to
take a $350,000 pay cut for it done
where do I sign but George Lucas
believed in himself he took that gamble
on himself and it paid off when it came
out Star Wars was the highest-grossing
film of all time until Steven Spielberg
overtook it with ET I think was five
years later that gamble paid off he
believed in himself the next one came
when he decided okay this first one
worked out well it's time for me to do
the sequel I own all the rights I can do
whatever I want with it he wanted to
create the Empire Strikes Back and he
wanted the finance at all himself where
usually you go and you work with a
production house like Fox duties that no
I noted of myself and it was gonna cost
him 30 million dollars to do it that was
basically all the money he
from his first movie who's in a port all
into that second movie if we didn't work
out he'd be bankrupt but he believed in
himself he took that bet and it worked
out and Pyrrha Strikes Back did
amazingly well
he kept releasing more star wars he
launched the Indiana Jones he launching
the whole bunch of other movies he's now
billionaire but it all started by that
belief in himself that's the difference
from just being a director making movies
and a billionaire entrepreneur owning
the movies he bet on himself he believed
in himself and you need to believe in
yourself too you need to believe in what
you're doing you have to be passionate
about your product your service you need
to believe in yourself you have to have
confidence that you can do this and you
need to believe that it's going to work
out you need to believe that if you
continue to follow your passion and you
continue to help people and you continue
to pour everything you have into it
then you will be successful it worked
out for George Lucas and it might just
make you a billionaire as well believe
those are you watching like the video
you can subscribe to the channel see
more just like it
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you soon don't forget to sign up for my
free newsletter its energy in your inbox
every single week hi I'm Jason Grif I
see you got a rise online calm and I
want to say Evan Carmichael's newsletter
is consistent fun inspiring and it's the
only newsletter I prioritize and look
forward to period